si a este hecho se suman ya 156 muertes
violentas como un saldo de fallecidos
contabilizados sólo durante el año 2021
según datos del servicio nacional las
personas privadas de libertad en el
ecuador de las muertes registradas que
se contabilizan continúa actualizando se
al menos 5 víctimas fueron decapitadas
los enfrentamientos entre bandas
delictivas se generan por pugnas en el
control de las cárceles y planificación
de delitos como el narcotráfico y el
microtráfico según informó el comandante
de la policía nacional el general fausto
buen año este enfrentamiento se produjo
por disputa entre pabellones y la
negativa de algunos presos por formar
parte de otras bandas delictivas desde
tempranas horas de la mañana se
escucharon detonaciones y se realizaron
fuertes operativos de control para
retomar el orden en la cárcel del
litoral en la ciudad de guayaquil la
mayoría de los fallecidos se produjo por
impactos de bala los enfrentamientos
ocurren un día después que el antiguo
director del servicio nacional de
atención integral a personas privadas de
libertad fausto cobo dejara el cargo y
fuera sustituido por el ex coronel del
ejército y nuevo director bolívar garzón
este hecho es la segunda masacre
carcelaria ocurrida en ecuador durante
el año 2021 mientras que la más violenta
ocurrió en febrero de este año donde
hubo 79 muertos el ejecutivo requiere
una inversión en infraestructura y
seguridad carcelaria y se adelantan
reuniones con el gobierno de eeuu para
poder así controlar su sistema
carcelario con un monto cercano a los 4
millones de dólares según cifras
oficiales